so you're going to need to tell the
backend API which client apps are
allowed to use it so here I am in the
conference API Java class up where i'm
specifying the endpoints api and you'll
notice that it has the client IDs and
this one here the constant API Explorer
client ID is the client ID for the api's
Explorer and then this one here
constants web client ID this is where
we're specifying the client IDs of other
apps not the API Explorer about other
web apps that are allowed to use this
application and if you knew the client
ID you could just write it out here if
you wanted but we're using this
constants class to hold our web client
ID so let's take a look at the constants
class and you'll see here in the
constants class that we define the
client ID and to start with there's no
value so it's replaced this with your
client ID so yeah it is a value but it's
not a real value so you're going to need
to go ahead and put your client ID in
here and just a reminder that you get
your client ID in the developers console
the client ID includes everything it's
not just the number it's the whole thing
that you see in developers console up to
the comp art if you see that on yours
and you can just copy and paste the
client ID from the developers console
what we've done is that we've said that
the applications with web client ID as
specified are allowed to access our
endpoints API so we basically granted
permission to the UI to use our
endpoints but another thing you have to
do is that on the client side on the
JavaScript side on the web the web app
UI side you have to when the when the
user logs in you need to run the
authentication process so you need to
identify yourself so you'll need to go
into the web app folder and then into
the jas folder and this time you're
going to have to go to a pas one of the
things that this file does is that it
runs your thin occation process when a
user logs in and you're going to need to
set the appropriate client ID in here so
you can go ahead and search
or client ID and it's uppercase client
hyphen ID and you'll see here again that
the client ID is just a placeholder so
you're going to need to put your client
ID right here and again that's the
client ID that you get from the
developers console here it's being used
for the client ID to identify itself
during the authentication process so
here's my client ID and then of course
save it and it hasn't mattered until now
that the client ID wasn't set here
because we haven't been using the web
pages in the conference central
application to test our functions I
think if you tried to log in using the
web pages you will have found that it
didn't work because it didn't have its
client ID set another thing you need to
make sure is that your consent screen
has a product name so again you would go
to your project in the developers
console go to api's and off then you
click consent screen here down here and
then first thing you see is it shows you
what your consent screen would look like
and this is the screen that gets shown
to users when they go to use your
application and you do need to scroll
down don't be put off that it's a little
bit faded just go ahead and scroll down
the email address does need to have a
value and then specify a product name
for your application basically your
application name okay one last thing you
need to do is to add the JavaScript
cross-origin in the client application
so for this you're going to go back to
the credentials screen in the developer
console your client ID for web
application you're going to add your
JavaScript origins so click Edit
settings make sure you're in the right
box for JavaScript origins and then you
need to add to hear you need to add the
URL for where your app is when it's
running on appspot and you need to add
the URL for localhost you'd go ahead and
add those if your app running on appspot
you do need to specify https full secure
connection for the app running on
localhost it's just HTTP because the dev
server running on localhost doesn't
support HTTPS so you go ahead and you
add
and you say update and basically what
this is doing is it's giving permission
to these URLs to run JavaScript to
access your app and you need to do this
even though this is the app itself right
I'm in here my app is cake heart and I'm
giving permission to cake heart to run
JavaScript to access k cut and after
you've done all these things you should
find that the my profile page works for
you